today on Battle Damage Joseph Urbano and
Tony Thompson and many more have
requested that we test this flat-screen
TV so don't touch that dial TVs don't
have dials anymore
here on Battle Damage we test the
physical limits of everyday technology
that means that this Samsung Smart TVs
120 Hertz for fresh rates likely won't
save it's cheap plastic frame from what
we have in store for it there are three
basic tests here on battle damage drop
from a normal height drop from really
high and finally we'll test the TV's
extreme limits the TV's big but the
stand is so wobbly I think it's gonna
absorb a lot of the initial impact for
this test at least what no way roll
action screens fine let's play binge
Honoria my feet
I think the stand help get acted like a
little spring I can win good boy it's a
smart TV bro it's smart it knows how to
fall like a cat
so the Smart TV survived five feet I
think it's about 50/50 chance at
surviving 15 okay here we go
action oh man
it's super loose everything's all jiggly
in there okay
Oh something oh that screens broken I
think this one's dead yeah for our third
test we're breaking out our custom
potato gun and charging it up to 100 psi
we've tested it before in my backyard
worked a little too well
ready look at that oh my god that is a
serious potato based dent I did not
expect that me neither
I thought the potato would just explode
right we had prepped some soda cans
thinking the potato wouldn't do much
damage we got it we got to shoot it so
sorry
TV here we go next time
ready go
stop the car stop the car ha ha ha this
bear it's deep oh there is that is a
mortal wound alright everyone thanks for
watching and remember that you can hit
us up in the comments or on social media
with a hashtag battle damage and you
could win a free broken TV no no not
really
Oh